John Kerry violates the Logan Act Rudy
Guiliani makes the rounds and there's a
reason that people think that feminist
studies professors are all sticks in the
mud I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
we have a lot to get to today but before
we get to any of it I mean a lot
happened over the weekend first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
ring so our sponsors over at ring there
the video doorbell company they allow
you to see and speak to anyone when they
come to your door well now they've sent
to some actual footage of ring busting
crooks in the acts here's a creeper it's
nighttime and a woman catches a strange
dude standing at her door and here's
what it looked like in the middle of
dinner can I help you how are you good
how are you good seen you in a while I
don't know who you are I'm Justin I met
you long time ago Evan god bless God huh
future senator from West Virginia right
they're trying to break this is what
ring video doorbell allows you to you
don't actually have to go to the door
and deal face-to-face with Justin
instead you can actually deal with it
from 3,000 miles away because there's a
lot happening at your front door ring
has a floodlight cam a spotlight cam
they let you bring them build a ring of
security around your entire property
stop crime before it happens help make
your neighborhood safer with ring save
up to 150 bucks off that ring of
security kit at ring comm slash men we
use it at the shapiro household and it
is really really great
it's ring comm slash spent a hundred and
fifty bucks off when you go to ring calm
slash bad news that slash bands they
know that we say alright so over the
weekend there's a lot of hubbub about
the Muller investigation and the evils
of the Trump administration and the
supposed dishonesty they're in but
there's another story that the media
seemed to have been paying less
attention to but that is in fact a lot
more troubling and it is this John Kerry
you recall him he's the former Secretary
of State and that guy is the worst
right John Kerry was one the worst
secretary of states of all time John
Carr well according to the Boston Globe
he has now been traveling across the
world attempting to fix up the Iran deal
like really he's not the Secretary of
State anymore he's just a guy and he's
going around the world he's going to
Tehran he's going to France and he's
trying to move behind the back of the
Trump administration in order to broker
some sort of resistance to Donald Trump
so here's the Boston Globe quote John
Kerry's bid to save one of his most
significant accomplishments as Secretary
of State took him to New York on a
Sunday afternoon to be
to go where more than a year after he
left office he engaged in some unusual
shadow diplomacy with the top-ranking
Iranian official now just before I go
any further let's recall something you
remember Mike Flynn Mike Flynn was the
former national security adviser and you
remember that Mike Flynn got in all
sorts of trouble because he lied to the
FBI about the fact that he had been
calling up the Russians after the
election and Justin before he was
supposed to take his official role as
national security adviser he'd been
calling up the Russian ambassador and
having conversations about sanctions
with regard to Israel and this was a big
deal right this was supposedly a Logan
Act violation the Logan Act is a is a
piece of legislation that may very well
be unconstitutional it's about two
centuries old it's been invoked I
believe once in a criminal prosecution
and it is that you are not allowed to
have your own foreign policy so I can't
go and purport to be speaking on behalf
of the United States government and go
conduct foreign policy against the
foreign policy of the United States
right that is a federal crime well Mike
Flynn was accused of doing just that in
talking to the Russians
even though he was the incoming national
security adviser and the president
Donald Trump had already been elected he
was already president-elect that was
considered criminal by a bunch of people
on the Left were deeply upset about the
Logan Act here you have an actual former
secretary of state who is not in any way
connected with the current government of
the United States going around and
attempting to perform his own foreign
policy on foreign soil as well as
domestic soil he sat down at the United
Nations with foreign minister Javad
Zarif was the foreign minister of Iran
to discuss ways of preserving the pacts
limiting Iran's nuclear weapons program
it was the second time in about two
months the two had met to strategize
over salvaging a deal they spent years
negotiating during the Obama
administration according to a person
briefed on the meetings with the Iran
deal facing its gravest threat since he
was signed in 2015
Kerry has been an aggressive yet
stealthy mission to preserve it using
his deep lists of contacts leaned during
his time as the top US diplomat to try
to apply pressure on the Trump
administration from the outside Trump is
now firing back by the way on on Kerry
Kerry met last month with the German
President Frank Walter Stein Mayer he's
been on the phone with top EU official
federica mogherini according to sources
he's also met with the French president
Emmanuel macron both in Paris and in New
York apparently discussing issues in
both French as well as English charm car
okay but this has gone relatively
unremarked upon by the mainstream media
remember again Mike Flynn might
in jail because he supposedly lied about
doing something that was completely not
illegal
but John Kerry is doing the same thing
except it could very well be illegal and
that is not a big deal at all so Donald
Trump has responded now to John Kerry
and Donald Trump tweeted out the United
States does not need John Kerry's
possible illegal shadow diplomacy on
this very badly negotiated Iran deal he
was the one that created this mess in
the first place
totally fair John Kerry has fired back
quote I think every American would want
every voice possible urging arange
remain in compliance with the nuclear
agreement that prevented a war secretary
Kerry I stay in touch with my former
counterparts around the world just like
every previous Secretary of State
Kendra's calm is it he continues to
suggest that it is his job to do foreign
policy again just points count hypocrisy
of a left that suggested that Michael
Flynn was the world's worst criminal for
calling the Russians well he was the
incoming second National Security
Advisor but the former Secretary of
State can do whatever he wants Rudy
Giuliani made this point on national TV
over the weekend he is of course exactly
correct certainly before April 5th 2018
the president knew that Michael Cohen
made these payments because he in fact
had reimbursed Michael Cohen I don't
know and I don't think it's at all
relevant anymore this is another tangent
like you know chasing the Flynn tangent
when it turns out that John Kerry is now
violating the Logan Act and nobody seems
to care you haven't asked me about right
and then Judy Lonnie is exactly right
about this nobody's asked about the
Kerry Logan Act violation of course by
the way we're now finding out the FBI is
not interested in investigating the text
sent between Carter page and Lisa sorry
Peter struck and Carter and Peter struck
and Lisa page so the the there was
there's no interest in investigating the
text of the FBI agents who apparently
were texting with each other while they
were having an affair
both were married about Donald Trump and
the investigation no interest in that
but every page of Donald Trump's memoirs
has to be dug through Michael Cohen has
to be dug out of the closet all of his
files have to be put before the FBI
again if this all turns out to be just a
campaign finance thing this is really
egregious overstep by the FBI if the
mother investigation turns out to be
nothing but a giant fishing expedition
that is going to reflect horribly not
only on the FBI but also on the DOJ that
has allowed this to go for remember rod
Rosenstein who
was the Deputy Attorney General who
appointed robert muller he has to set
the basis for the Malheur investigation
he actually has to set the limits of the
Muller investigation and the mobile
investigation was originally supposed to
be limited to Trump Russia collusion and
all of the elements that were related
thereto but now we're all the way at
Michael Cohen and Michael Kohn and Paul
mana for and all this kind of stuff now
judges are beginning to look at the
scope of the Muller investigation and
they're saying this has nothing to do
with your original investigation now
does that mean that Paul Manafort for
example is off the hook no you could
have an attorney general and in the
district of New York suddenly take up
the manna for case but the question is
what is the scope the proper scope of
the Muller investigation and again when
you go back and you read the original
Rosen Stein memo that was appointing its
robert muller to the special counsel it
was quite it was quite circumscribed it
was not a broad mandate it was Trump
Russia collusion alone but now they've
gone far beyond that and that's why over
the weekend according to Politico a
federal judge has rejected special
counsel Robert Mueller's request to
delay the first court hearing in a
criminal case charging three Russian
companies and 13 Russian citizens with
using social media and other means to
foment strife among Americans in advance
of the 2016 US presidential election in
a brief order Saturday evening US
District Court Judge Dabney Friedrich
offered no explanation for her decision
to deny a request prosecutors made
Friday to put off a spent scheduled
Wednesday arraignment for a Concord
management and consulting one of the
three firms charged in the case so the
13 people charged in the high-profile
indictment in February considered
unlikely to ever appear in a US Court
and the judges are looking askance at
Muller's prosecutors they're saying that
Muller's prosecutors do not have the
authority to actually go after anyone on
these grounds the prosecutors wrote that
the US government has attempted service
and summons by delivering copies of them
to the office of the prosecutor general
of Russia to be delivered to the
defendants that office however declined
to accept the summons the government has
submitted service requests to the
Russian government pursuant to a mutual
legal assistance treaty ok Mueller's
team sent a formal copy of the sanctions
to all these people and then they
submitted it to the judge and the judge
is not interested the judges is is
basically saying that this is a waste of
time that there is no supporting legal
authority to any of this again if this
all turns out to be a giant wild-goose
chase it's the worst it is one of the
worst abuses of power in modern American
history honestly to run the president
you ragged for a year and a half and
bankrupt a bunch of people in the Trump
administration over nothing is a pretty
astonishing thing now meanwhile the
Michael Kohn investigation which is not
taking place under the auspices of
Muller is continuing a pace that of
course was an FBI raid on Michael
Cohen's office Michael Kohn you'll
recall is the personal attorney of
President Trump and that investigation
is being pursued not by Muller's office
but by the u.s. district attorney in
Southern District of New York so Rudy is
a temp that Rudy who's Trump's new
lawyer is attempting to go around and
explain why Trump didn't do anything
illegal the case he's making for why
Trump didn't do anything illegal is he
saying there was no campaign finance
implication at all to Trump pink stormy
Daniels 130,000 dollars to shut up he
says basically Trump has a slush fund
with Michael Khan
there are probably payments out of this
fund regularly to shut up stories about
Donald Trump which means this had
nothing to do with the campaign so it
may be gross it may be seedy it may be
yucky but it's not actually a violation
of law that's the case that Rudy was
making you said hehehe this was a
regular arrangement he had Michael
constituted Michael Kahn make payments
to other women for the president I'd
have no knowledge of that
but I would think if it was necessary
yes he made payments for the president
or he he'd conducted business for the
president which means he had legal fees
monies laid out and expenditures which I
have on my bills to my to my clients
okay so the case that Giuliani is making
legally here people are saying people
are going crazy over this Kellyanne
Conway is saying I'm not sure why anyone
would say what Giuliani is saying right
here's Kellyanne Conway trying to move
away from Rudy Giuliani but Giuliani has
a legal strategy here and it does make
some sense I'll explain in a second I
don't know why anyone would say that I
would not characterize it the way the
President himself characterized it as
not a campaign expenditure all I can
tell you is that as the campaign manager
for them winning part of the campaign
this never crossed my desk I was never
made aware of this okay so the case
that's being made by Giuliani and sort
of here by Kellyanne Conway is that
Trump regularly pays off his mistresses
and so if you paid off a mistress right
before the election that was by
coincidence because he basically gives a
giant chunk of change to Michael Cohen
every year and Michael Khan basically
shuts down any rumors that he's having
sex with porn stars that's that's
Michael Cohen's basic job that's not
completely implausible but it is not
great for the President of the United
States to be saying that except that
it's Trump and we all know that he's
doing this stuff anyway no one's really
shocked by any of this and if you are
shocked just be
as you haven't watched Donald Trump any
time for the last 40 years I mean this
has been his shtick for a really long
time
the real danger to Trump you know if you
can make this case then it's not a
danger Trump the real danger Trump is
only going to be self-imposed and I'll
explain in a second why the only person
who can damage Trump in a lot of these
legal proceedings is gonna be Trump
himself but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at movements so
you've heard me talk about movement and
you know those two college dropouts that
started their own watch company they've
now sold 2 million watches in a hundred
and sixty countries and the
revolutionising fashion on the belief
that style should not break the bank
I own two movement watch they own
sunglasses for movement my wife own
sunglasses for movement they've doubled
the number of watch styles lately but
they are still expanding it's just
fantastic their movement watches start
at ninety five bucks at a department
store you're looking at 400 to 500
dollars and the watches are all really
durable Mike my son beats the crap out
of my watch it looks just as the same as
it did when it came out of the box
brand-new I have a really beautiful
looking watch it's really really nice
clean simple and really just effective
they they look like they're four hundred
five hundred dollar watches and it's a
hundred bucks movement figured that by
selling online they could cut out the
middleman and that's just what they've
done it's classic design quality
construction styled minimalism my dad
has one of these watches as well get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
shapiro cy movement keeps growing go to
MVM t.com slash appearin again get 15%
off with free shipping and free returns
their watches are just terrific go to em
VMT calm slash / and they've more than
that now they have bracelets and they
also have the and they also have the
sunglasses so you can basically get
everything you need over at MVM t.com
slash prepare to go out looking stylish
mbm tea calm / up here that's movement
join the movement use that / apparel let
them know that we sent you okay so the
only person who can really damage Trump
it seems if Trump is telling the truth
and he had this giant slush fund and he
was always paying off mr. says then the
: thing will probably come to nothing
Cohn might be hit with a campaign
finance violation but that's about it
Cohn might be hit for some ancillary
violations but it's not gonna damage
Trump which brings us back to the model
or investigation the only thing that
could hurt President Trump in the Muller
investigation is he goes off half-cocked
and decides that would be a very very
smart idea for him to suddenly for no
reason at all fire robert muller because
muller is not going anywhere and he's
annoying me i'm gonna rip off the
band-aid envira that would be a huge
mistake and it seems like that might
the way that he is leaning a lot of his
closest allies are now attempting to put
restrictions on the molar investigation
again I think this is a mistake not
because the molar investigation is is
acting properly I don't know you don't
know no one knows because we're only
hearing leaks but because it gives the
impression that he's trying to hide
something even if he's really just
annoyed I Trump fires people when he
gets annoyed he doesn't fire them when
they're ineffective he doesn't fire them
when they're bad at their job he fires
them when he personally is annoyed by
them and this is the case with James
Comey now it's the case with robert
muller but you can see that the
groundwork is being set by certain
members of the Trump administration to
do this so here's Rudy Trump's lawyer
again who's saying you know if Muller
grants if he sends a subpoena if there's
a grand jury subpoena for President
Trump to testify Trump does not have to
comply happens if Robert Muller
subpoenas the president will you comply
well we don't have to he's the president
United States we can assert the same
privilege as other presidents have
President Clinton negotiated a deal in
which he didn't admit the effectiveness
of the Seban they testify but he did
testify before the grandchildren is the
president willing to do that but only
for two and a half hours only with an
arranged format okay so Rudy's wrong
Trump will comply with the subpoena if
the subpoena comes down because
otherwise he'll be held in contempt of
court presumably it could create all
sorts of legal problems for him he will
go it will be pre negotiated and he will
probably test by but no no guarantee
there's gonna be subpoena anyway it's
the militant stance that Rudy is taking
against Muller that's really interesting
here you're seeing this also from Devin
Nunes Devin Nunes of course is the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman and he's
saying that he wants to hold Jeff
Sessions in contempt the Attorney
General he's saying the DOJ is
stonewalling Congress on a bunch of
material now the DOJ does have an
obligation to turn over all that
material Congress is an oversight body
for the DOJ and the DOJ does have to
turn over these materials the DOJ is
saying listen we don't have to turn over
confidential materials in the middle of
an investigation because that doesn't
comply with regulation Nunes is now
saying he wants to hold sessions in
contempt now remember this is Nunes
doing Trump's dirty work
Trump doesn't like sessions he's angry
sessions he believes sessions never
should have recused himself in the first
place so here's Devin hoon saying let's
hold sessions in content remember
sessions is Trump's own attorney general
two weeks ago we sent a letter to
attorney general Jeff Sessions the
classified letter it per usual it was
ignored
not acknowledged just completely ignored
so last week we sent a subpoena and then
on Thursday we discovered that they are
not going to comply with our subpoena so
what are you gonna do very important
information that we need so what are you
gonna do the only thing left that we can
do is we have to move quickly to hold
the Attorney General of the United
States and contempt okay so in just
second I'm going to show you more
evidence that the the Trump
administration seems to be moving
against Muller and seems to be moving
against anyone who would protect Muller
so for example Rudy Giuliani he comes
out yesterday he says listen here's what
Trump wants Trump wants the Hillary
Clinton treatment from Robert Muller so
Hillary Clinton got kid-glove treatment
from the FBI and the DOJ that's what
Trump wants as well again the
implication being that if Muller doesn't
give that sort of treatment then
suddenly he's going to turn around and
fire Mahler I'd rather have the Hillary
Clinton treatment hours no he was
two-and-a-half hours in the grand jury
approximately maybe three we'll take
three but Hillary Clinton's treatment is
what I'm looking for and that is know
what no wonder Rose only a QA and then
we get the questions in advance and they
write the report two weeks before ok so
again this is this is I think the move
that's being made by the Trump
administration let's shut this thing
down all right shut it down shut it down
now what's interesting is that the
people who have political aspirations
inside the Trump administration are not
saying quite the same thing right nikki
Haley is saying no you know let's leave
let's let this probe go and the reason
she's saying that is of course she
doesn't want to be seen as someone who's
stonewalling on behalf of the president
I have a feeling there's a nikki Haley
Donald Trump confrontation coming
sometime in the relatively near future
here here is Haley's statement when
asked about the Moller investigation
should the president shut it down no not
at all I mean anything that comes like
this it should play its part it should
go through the process but they need to
do it quickly for the good of the
country this investigation needs to
happen quickly okay so this is really
it's interesting because again I think
Haley is correct but I think Trump is is
leaning away from this now there's a
danger for Democrats here too I've
talked about the danger to trump if
Trump were to fire Muller it would look
like he was stonewalling like he was
covering something up there's a danger
for Democrats the Democrats have staked
their entire 2018 and 2020 hopes on
people hate Trump right Trump everyone
hates from so much
that we don't have to provide anything
in in the form of an alternative we
would have to be good at our jobs we
don't have to have a program we don't
have to have good candidates all we have
to do is just yell and scream about
Trump this is not going to work right
now they are staking a lot of 2018 on if
you put us in a majority in the house
then we will impeach President Trump but
the polls are not really very much in
support of the idea of impeaching
President Trump most Americans are not
thrilled with the idea that they're
gonna meet impeachment hearings and
throw Trump out of office on the basis
of what on the basis of nothing right
now right Jonathan Karl is right that
the best thing that could happen
Jonathan Karl the reporter from ABC News
he's right the best thing that could
probably happen here for the Republicans
is for Democrats to start pushing
impeachment on the basis of zero
evidence at this point the Republicans
that are running this strategy in terms
of from Capitol Hill don't necessarily
want that it's a district-by-district
state-by-state effort some of those
candidates will have to distance
themselves from Donald Trump but the
Trump political team believes that you
have to make this all about you have to
make this a referendum on impeachment or
referendum on the president and I think
that's exactly right I mean I think that
if the Democrats push for impeachment
that backfired against Republicans after
they tried to impeach Clinton in 1998
1999 and I think it will backfire
against yeah I think it'll backfire
against Democrats if they try now
Democrats believe this too Karen Finney
is a former spokesperson for Hillary
Clinton and she is admitting that if
Democrats try to push for impeachment
it's actually gonna be very bad for them
and the Democrats cannot let that happen
because I agree with you that is the way
to fire up that base and Matt I disagree
with you mean part of why the messaging
from the Democrats does matter is
they've got to try to keep the
president's numbers as low as they can
and create as much of a wedge for
Republicans who are either running for
reelection or running in these races
it's part of what we've seen the
challenge that they've had already in
these special elections but this is the
problem the Democrats have with their
own base well the while the politicos
understand that you can get your own
base revved up with the impeachment talk
most Americans don't like it the
Democratic base only wants to talk
impeachment and Michael Mills the
execrable Michael Knowles he actually
made a really good point over the
weekend only time you'll ever hear me
say this Michael Mills actually came out
and he said listen stormy Daniels is the
de facto head of the Democratic Party
and that's basically right there now
using storming Daniels as the physical
embodiment of the Trump lies argument
and you can see this right on SNL they
featured stormy Daniels on Saturday
night and she got a big cheer
stormy Daniels why cuz she slept at the
president once and then she reneged on a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
settlement agreement but listen to the
cheers she gets from the crowd when she
appears and then this this little
segment on SNL turns into it what it
really turns into is is her stumping for
Trump's and Pietschmann in the crowd
cheering it along this is Michael Cohen
are you alone yes and what are you
wearing so what up girl hello come on
stormy stop making such a big deal about
this everyone knows it's just an act
I work in adult films we're not really
known for our acting just tell me what
do you need for this to all go away a
resignation okay so stop it there okay
this is this is what the Democrats want
what the Democrats think is that stormy
Daniels gonna be responsible for Trump
leaving which is why this gets big
cheers now I want to show you that the
Democrats don't have exactly the same
perspective when it comes to Democrats
because this is not the first time that
a presidential paramour has appeared on
Saturday Night Live okay it happened
before in 1998 actually and I'll show
you what that looked like in just a
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at stamps.com so these
days you can get practically everything
on demand well one thing that you
heretofore have not been able to get
onto man is stamps where you have to go
down to the post office and you have to
wait in line post office is great but
you might not have time to leave the
office well instead now you can sit at
your desk and get all this done with
stamps calm you can access all the
amazing services at the post office
right for me to ask 24/7 when it is
convenient for you we use stamps calm
here at the Daily wire offices it saves
us a lot of time and it saves us a lot
of money because time is money you can
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package using your own
computer and printer you can print it
out and onto the envelope you can print
it out onto stickers you can print it
out onto a piece of paper and tape it to
the envelope and then you can just mail
it right you never have to worry about
going to the post office again which is
great and right now you can use Shapiro
for a special offer okay
was up to 55 bucks of free postage a
digital scale and a four week trial so
don't wait go to stamps calm and before
you do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that stamps comm
promo code Shapiro when you do that
again you get that special deal 55 bucks
of free postage a digital scale and a
four week trial post office is great
stamps.com makes it even more convenient
go to stamps comm and again enter promo
code Shapiro after you click on that
radio radio microphone at the top of the
homepage ok so you know when you look at
an SNL's treatment of stormy Daniels
what you see is that they're treating
her like she's a heroin the Democratic
Party believes that storming Daniels is
going to save them she's gonna come like
deus ex machina gonna come from the
outside and somehow save the Democratic
Party from the predations of Donald
Trump well people are pointing out that
this is not the first time that a former
lover of the President of the United
States has appeared on television on SNL
particularly Monica Lewinsky did an
actual cameo in 1998 but you actually
have to see how Monica Lewinsky treats
Bill Clinton in this little cameo it's
not about Bill Clinton's resignation
anymore she basically touched him for
being a bit of a sleaze but that's about
it and there is a difference there is a
difference here's what it looked like in
1998 when Monica Lewinsky was on SNL
sky at work is considerably older than
me and also he's my boss Oh your boss oh
well Monica maybe you should answer this
uh well I'd say it's not a good idea to
get involved with people you work with
believe me first people around the
office start gossiping and the next
thing you know your face is all over
Arabic newspapers yeah I know whatever
what happens to me all the time
okay so again it turns into the sort of
cutting isn't it funny that she had an
affair with the President of the United
States but is that Dora stormy Daniels
demanding a resignation
there isn't resignation porn it's just
porn and it's basically how the media
treated Bill Clinton as opposed to how
they treat Donald Trump this is why the
Democratic Party has a problem if they
run on resignation of Donald Trump they
will lose but the base insists that this
is exactly what they run on right this
is the only thing that the Left cares
about right now is Donald Trump their
entire universe revolves around the
giant son of Donald Trump in the very
center it's an amazing amazing thing to
watch because there's so much else going
on this is why they're now hailing John
McCain as a hero Sir John McCain is
unfortunately dying and he knows that
right I mean he's gonna go pretty soon
and he's already planning who he wants
his funeral so the left is very very
excited because McCain has said he does
not want Donald Trump at his funeral
right according to NBC News people close
to Senator McCain have told the White
House the alien Arizona Republican does
not want Trump to attend his funeral I
would like vice president Mike Pence to
come and said a source close to McCain
confirmed to NBC News we've been
battling an aggressive form of brain
cancer for nearly a year and he's back
home in Arizona after undergoing surgery
last month and he's been ripping into
Trump he obviously is doing a new HBO
documentary in which he's gonna
criticize Trump now I think that's
McCain's prerogative listen if I were
McCain what I want Donald Trump a guy
who said I wasn't a war hero at my
funeral a guy who consistently used me
as his foil and my funeral probably not
right and when you're dying you
definitely have to pick who comes to
your funeral so all these people who are
like God it's so terrible how could he
how could he ripped from like that not
wanting him in his funeral to be fair
Donald Trump was ripping McCain first
but it's the media's response to this
that I find truly fascinating the media
are suddenly over the moon about John
McCain again because John McCain has
been resistant to trump everything for
the left revolves around Donald Trump
that is not a good way for you to run a
political party it actually makes you it
makes your political base nuts
I think that there's a good case we made
the Barack Obama made the Republican
base a little bit crazy and I think that
the same thing is happening to the
Democratic base with regard to Donald
Trump except a lot more so except a lot
more so ok so meanwhile I have to tell
you a couple of amazing stories so first
this is you wonder about the extremism
of the left here's an example of the
extremism of the left so on Sunday the
Chronicle of Higher Education reported
on a supremely important development a
male professor made a joke about
lingerie in an elevator and who else was
in the elevator a gender studies
professor so you can predict how this
thing was going to go according to
Katherine Mangan whose political of
higher education political theory
professor Richard Nedley BAU of King's
College was in an elevator with a bunch
of other humans including professor
Simona Cerrone who teaches Women's and
Gender Studies at Merrimack College as
she is a professional professional
useless person and sure Oni who clearly
had been conditioned to submit to the
patriarchy she offered to hit buttons on
the elevator and that's when Li bout did
the unthinkable he jokingly asked for
the women's lingerie department which
has been like a joke since the 1950s
that you got an elevator with a bunch of
people and then somebody says which
button would you like to and they say
lingerie department yeah just as like a
stupid joke so his buddies those jerks
those patriarchal jerks they laughed how
dare they so what did this lady do ok
this women's studies professor
complained to the International Studies
Association just as an empowered woman
would she wouldn't she whined to the to
the male bosses of the ISA she'd
tremblingly wrote quote I am still
trying to come to terms of the fact that
we froze and didn't confront him for
making a joke about the women's lingerie
department in an elevator ok they
launched a full investigation of Li Bao
why because here's what Li bout dead she
wrote to him and he wrote back quote I
certainly had no desire to insult women
or make you feel uncomfortable and then
he suggested that sure Oni who was born
in Romania and raised in Israel might
have misinterpreted his remark when he
was young in the 1950s he said it was a
standard gag line to ask the elevator
operator for the hardware and lingerie
floor as the one were in a department
store and then you wrote like you I'm
strongly opposed to the exploitation
coercion or humiliation of women yes
such evils continue it seems to me to
make sense to direct our attention to
real offences not those that are
imagined or marginal by making a
complaint to ISA that I consider
frivolous and I expect will be judged
this way by the Ethics Committee you may
be directing
I'm an effort away from the real
offenses that trouble us both but this
was the big problem right why was this
is probably cuz he's doubling down and
not only that he was mansplaining he
mansplain to the gender studies
professor you must never mansplain to if
gender studies professor that she's
being an idiot
I had too bad that she couldn't woman
understand but he had to man explain it
to her and that was the big problem and
Andrew kleavon's lying there about woman
woman understanding according to the
Association this was the cruelest cut of
all that leave out didn't just bow
groveling Li before her and say I wish I
had never made that lingerie joke I know
I know it was just the same just the
same as forced abortions in China but
you know I really apologize now
so she says it didn't feel frivolous
instead the association said that Li Bao
this professor had to write an
unequivocal apology Li Bao said no
because he's not a ridiculous stupid
instead he wrote an email calling
the entire situation quote a horrifying
and chilling example of political
correctness that encourages others to
censor their remarks for fear of
retribution retribution much Huronia
this email professor was steadfast she
wrote quote for decades women and other
marginalized groups in the academy had
to put up with white men who decided
what counts as violation and what is
frivolous as someone who has dedicated
her life to confronting sexism and other
forms of discrimination and oppression
in academic spaces I cannot and will not
remain silent when misogyny is at play
here the swelling music from behind and
you get the upshot with the lights
behind her and you see her in profile
she looks out staring into the Sun
because of the magical thing she's just
done in resisting a joke about a women's
lingerie department just amazing amazing
courage and then people wonder why
people think that gender studies
professors are humorless colds you never
want to spend any time in an elevator
with probably because they're humorless
schools that you wouldn't want to spend
any time in an elevator with my goodness
I know but this is the extent to which
the left has gone extreme and I have a
couple more examples that I want to give
you in just a second first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at Tommy
John so Tommy John is the 21st century
clothing company they're famous for
their no wedgie guarantee and they are
now celebrating 10 years of underwear
excellence
ok all of their underwear is supremely
comfortable not only this is supremely
comfortable you don't have to trust me
maybe the best pair or you'll ever wear
or it's free guarantee and it's not the
most comfortable underwear you have ever
worn
Tommy John will
pick up the tab there's a reason the
Tommy John has sold over five million
pairs of underwear in ten years more
than half a million dudes had switched
Tommy John these proprietary fabrics
innovative designs to make sure the legs
never ride up the waistband never rolls
down it is impossible to get a wedgie
again that is something I definitely
could have used in high school Plus
Tommy John's time-saving quick-draw fly
is effective and useful and again you
don't have to believe me they have a
best pair where you'll you'll ever wear
or it's free guarantee so if you try it
you don't like it it's now free hurry to
Tommy John calm right now slash
Shapiro's for 20% off your first order
that's Tommy John calm slash Shapiro's
for 20% off your first order again Tommy
John comm / Shapiro and get 20% off that
first order the underwear are incredibly
comfortable they also have a women's
line as well check it out again you
don't have to trust me try it you don't
like it it's free Tommy John comm /
appear for 20% off it's just the best
there is
ok so meanwhile speaking of extremism on
the Left there's a CNN columnist who's
now explaining that violence all
violence in the United States is due to
the patriarchy it is due to the
patriarchy it's not due to guns it's not
due to lack of fathers in the community
it's due to the patriarchy I'll explain
the extremism of this idiotic
perspective in just a second but for
that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm when you go over daily
we're calm you get the rest of this show
live the rest of Clavin still alive
there are some Knowles's show live you
also if you get the annual subscription
get this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels left this year's hot or
cold tumbler it is spectacular you will
love it and by the way when you're a
subscriber you also get to take part in
the conversation
yeah the Contin the next episode of the
conversation is coming up Tuesday May
15th 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
all of your questions will be answered
by The Daily wires Michael Knowles I
know I know why you think Michaels has
anything to answer you is beyond me but
you get to ask him any question that you
want including why he has hairless legs
Elisha Kraus will be there to host it
and keep Knowles in line which is a
really really difficult job I do not
envy her that this month's episode will
stream live on Daily wires YouTube and
Facebook pages it's free for everyone to
watch only subscribers can actually ask
the questions to ask a question as a
subscriber you just go over to our
website daily we're calm you head over
to the conversation page to watch the
live stream after that you start typing
into the daily wired chat box Michael
will answer questions as they come in
for the entire hour so once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by Michael Mills
Tuesday May 15th 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
also I just wanted to know thank you for
subscribing last week and thank you for
watching our Sunday special so the Ben
Shapiro Sunday special came out and it
was the interview with Jordan Peterson
it's been getting amazing numbers and I
think rightly so because it's a really
good interview Jordan and said it's the
best interview that he's done in a
really long time maybe ever and I
appreciate that our next week's
interview I'm not gonna announce I guess
now you'll have to wait to hear who the
guest is but it's another big-name
guests for next Sunday we're gonna have
a big name guest every Sunday because
that's what we do here so check all of
that out we just want to listen go over
to iTunes go over to YouTube please
subscribe please leave us a review we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
you
so talking about the polarization and
extremism of the left and the fact that
they want to impeach Donald Trump the
fact that you have Femina studies
professors who are attempting to shut
down jokes and elevators well the latest
example comes courtesy of CNN airs
community organized there in Richard
Edmund Vargas and he has finally cracked
the code to violence in American society
it is not guns
it is not lack of fathers it is
testicles testicles are the real problem
according to Vargas quote it's safe to
say there is something wrong with how
our culture socializes men so Vargas has
spent a lot of time with prisoners and
what he's found is that the patriarchy
is to blame he writes this again visit
cnn.com patriarchy is a social system
that defines men is being inherently
violent dominant in controlling while
rewarding them with powerful being that
way it is no secret especially these
days that we live in a patriarchal
society why are we continually surprised
when a man takes up arms and commits
mass murder first of all we live in a
less patriarchal society than any time
in human history if by patriarchal
society you mean the rule of men okay
there are more women in positions of
power now than at any time in the
history of humanity beyond that this
idea that men are continuously taking up
arms and committing mass murder is not
true those numbers have been declining
steadily for the last several decades
violent crime rates have been in
consistent decline since 1994 second men
constitute most violent criminals in
every society no matter how feminist
they are every society ever men are more
violent than women it's just the way
that it works it's not the patriarchy
it's because men are built to be more
violent than women and finally it's
really funny that this guy wants to
blame the entire patriarchy when it is
in fact lack of men in society that is
leading to a violent uptick where there
is a violent uptick okay single
motherhood is one of the leading
indicators in American society of
criminality among young men it's very
weird that Vargas is willing to blame a
culture of American patron patriarchal
ism at large for violence rather than
looking at specific cultures that have a
violence problem and say okay what do
all of these things have in common it
has nothing to with race there are
violent white cultures their violent
black cultures their violent Hispanic
cultures one of the things that they
have in common is lack of men in the
community teaching boys that they are
safe but they don't need to react
violently and that it is in fact bad to
react violently instead Vargas blames
cartoons video games and contemporary
politicians which is just idiotic
cartoons have been around since the
1940s 1930s
they've always been violent they are
less violent now than at any time
probably in the history of cartoons
watch cartoons now really
a lot less violent than they were even
in Tom and Jerry's day right that's why
in the Simpsons they mocked the old
cartoons with itchy and scratchy right
the uber violent cartoons from itchy and
scratchy that's supposed to be making
fun of the cartoons isn't it's Tom and
Jerry that's what it's supposed to be
mocking okay those cartoons have gotten
less violent video games very little
evidence to show that playing video
games makes you violent in fact there's
virtually no evidence to show that and
contemporary politicians again blaming
Trump I understand it just shows how
Trump is warped to the minds of left
blaming Trump for optics and violence is
insane considering that whatever uptick
in violence has happened in the last
couple of years predated him the uptick
in violent crime was due to the Ferguson
effect in 2015 in 2016 as cops stopped
getting aggressive in high crime areas
and that led to an increase in crime
generally so where's Vargas getting his
evidence for the idea that American
patriot patriarchal the America's
patriarchal society is responsible for
the evils of violence here's what he
says in my own life I was taught by
patriarchy that real men don't ask for
help and because of the ways that
patriarchy is racialized I was taught
that black men like myself were supposed
to act in certain ways Hardin shallow
unaccountable when I was 19 I followed
the script and decided that committing
robberies was an acceptable way to deal
with the fact that I couldn't pay my
rent but my girlfriend offered to help
me pay it I saw accepting a woman's help
as weakness and decided to rob instead
that led to me being sentenced to ten
years in state prison it was all a
little bit vague like where's the
patriarchy who told him this who
socialized him who was it his dad was it
his brothers was it all there it was a
gang members like who did it
he doesn't say because instead again
this is one of the big problems in
having political conversations when
people say the problem is white
privilege the problem is the patriarchy
the problem is is generalized American
institutional racism none of this is
helpful because you're not naming me a
specific problem I can deal with it's
like me saying the problem is society
what the hell am I supposed to do about
society what are you supposed to do
about society the answer is you can't do
anything about society you actually have
to name me the specific problem then I
can help you fight otherwise you're just
shouting in the wind and blaming people
you disagree with for your problems
Vargas is solution in the end is
feelings he says that young men must be
taught to share and regulate the
spectrum of human emotions or maybe what
we actually need is more of a patriarchy
a system of
bringing up boys haiya system men
growing up roughhousing with their sons
teaching them the limits of violent play
as the system of men who are inculcating
in their sons the idea that they have to
be protectors of women and children that
they are not to act out violently maybe
you need more men not fewer men maybe
you need more masculinity not less
masculinity maybe testosterone is not
the problem it's unch annulled
testosterone because there's no other
men there to deter the use of
testosterone
you know why boys don't listen to their
moms because boys very often are
physically more powerful than their moms
okay any talk to any guy who's who's
alive now right any man who has lived
through the age of 16 or 17 and asked
them if they were really intimidated by
their mom the answer is no but ask any
of those men who grew up with powerful
dads if they were afraid that if they
cross the line their dad was gonna whoop
their but the answer is yes the answer
is yes that was always a deterrent you
need a system in fact it's not even
having a father in the home it turns out
that's the most important thing it's
having a lot of men in the community at
large there's that study that I talked
about a few weeks ago from from Harvard
in which they they looked at violent
crime statistics and what they found is
that the leading indicator of depressing
violent crime wasn't actually having a
father in the home who's having lots of
fathers in the neighborhood it was
having an entire system of men so
getting rid of the men isn't the
solution and just an feminizing men
isn't the solution either
the answer is channeling masculinity in
a positive way that matters channeling
masculinity in a special positive way
and you need men to do that now
meanwhile speaking of the racialism of
the left there's a long five thousand
word essay by tana he see Coates now on
Kanye West Donaghy see Coates is
considered one of the great writers of
our time for the life of me I don't know
why I think that he uses very flowing
romantic language he likes run-on
sentences he's very fond of paragraph
long lists his writing has been favored
by all of the great intelligentsia
he's considered the heir to James
Baldwin the the racial writer from the
1960s 70s 80s 50s and Tunney's he coats
as a long essay in which he is very very
angry with Kanye West why is he angry
with Kanye West he's angry with Kanye
West because Kanye West says that he
wants to think outside the box so what
does Donaghy see Coates to Kanye West's
are
I'm not just a black man I'm an
individual and that means I can have an
individual perspective and Tonya he
coaches the answer to this is stop being
an individual with a perspective be a
black man so he begins his five thousand
word essay with an ode to Michael
Jackson he says Michael Jackson was God
but not just God in scope and power
though there was certainly that but God
in his great mystery God and how a child
would hear tell of him God and how he
lived among the legend in the lore God
because the Walkman was still uncommon
and I was young and could not count on
the car radio because my parents live
between NPR and WTOP or such such
language ah and he talked about how
Michael Jackson was his God but then
Michael Jackson started turning white he
says that he had always been dying dying
to be white right this what he says
about Michael Jackson okay that's that's
pretty overwrought language by the way
it's also kind of nasty because it turns
out that Jackson had vitiligo right I
mean so Jackson there there was a lot of
suspicion that he was bleaching his skin
but it turns out that on his autopsy
they actually found he did outfit till
ago which actually makes her skin white
and he would bleach the rest of his skin
to match the vitiligo he can't bleach to
the till ago so you know again that
that's it easy for coats to rip on him
from wanting to be listen they're a
bunch of reasons drip on Michael Jackson
the skin stuff I think his beliefs of it
but according to according to Coates
that's because Michael Jackson was a
sellout what does that have to do with
Kanye West he says Kanye a God in this
time okay first of all if you're if you
are worshiping cultural figures of guys
you got a bigger problem on your hands
than Kanye West his Kanye West God in
this time awakened recently from a long
public slumber to embrace Donald Trump
he hailed Trump as a brother a fellow
bearer of Dragon energy and impugned
those who objected as suppressors of
unpopular questions thought police whose
tactics were based on fear which is
basically true and then Kanye West and
then Tony he see Coates plays the
thought police right he says that Kanye
like Jackson before him is trying to
escape his blackness he says that Donald
Trump is is nothing new
he says the tragedy is so old but even
within it there are actors some who have
chosen resistance in some like West who
have blithely chosen collaboration so
apparently he is now a collaborator and
here is the here's the amazing part of
this of this ridiculously long and silly
article he says West is the great
betrayer
he's the great betrayer why because when
Jackson sang and danced when West
samples our rhymes they're tapping into
a power formed under all the killing
all the beatings all the rape and
plunder that made America the gift can
never wholly belong to a singular artist
free of expectation and scrutiny because
the gift is no more solely theirs than
the suffering that produced it so in
other words Kanye West is not an
individual he is merely a sort of a sort
of embodiment of black culture
collectively and therefore he can't be
an individual he has to be that
embodiment of black culture and so here
is how he here is where he gets the
points is what Kanye West seeks is what
Michael Jackson sought liberation from
the dictates of that we the we being
black people in his visit with West the
rapper T I was stunned to find that West
despite his endorsement of Trump had
never heard of the travel ban he didn't
know the things that we know because
he's removed himself from society to a
point where it doesn't reach him t I
said West's calls has struggled the
right to be a free thinker and he is
indeed championing a kind of freedom a
white freedom freedom without
consequence freedom without criticism
freedom to be proud and ignorant freedom
to profit off of people in one moment
and abandon them in the next a
stand-your-ground freedom of freedom
without responsibility without hard
memory a Monticello without slavery a
Confederate freedom the freedom of
Jhansi Calhoun John C Calhoun talked
about the glories and merits of slavery
not the freedom of Harriet Tubman which
calls you to risk your own not the
freedom of Nat Turner which calls you to
give even more but a conquerors freedom
freedom of the strong built an antipathy
or indifference to the weak the freedom
of rape buttons P grabbers and fu anyway
be freedom of oil and invisible Wars the
freedom of suburbs drawn with red lines
the freedom the white freedom of
Calabasas so Kanye West said I want to
think for myself and kind and Tana he's
he coats his response is you're just
like John C Calhoun you're just like the
slaveholder you're just like the person
who killed Trayvon Martin you are a you
are looking for the white freedom of
calabasas um I think that Tonya he coats
just proved Tonya at West Point
Kanye West's entire point was you won't
let me think for myself because you
suggest that if I do then I am betraying
black people everywhere and Tonya he C
code says you're right you are betraying
black people everywhere by thinking for
yourself stop that return to being a cog
in the machine because after all your
culture is not your own your music is
not your own your creativity is not your
own it's mine right you are he has a
Marxist view of society in which we are
all outgrowth of the social milieu in
which we live and Kanye West is just
that and if he betrays that social
milieu then he has become a traitor a
race traitor he finishes up tiny he's he
coats by saying I wonder what he might
be if he could find himself back into
connection back to that place he's
he sought not a disconnected freedom of
AI but a black freedom that called him
back back to the bone and drum back to
Chicago back to home okay well maybe he
doesn't need to be called back to
Chicago back to home maybe home is where
you make it because you're an individual
but this clash between collective and
individual is too much for Tonya he see
Coates to stand it's too much for the
left to stand and that is a route
conflict that is not going to go away
anytime soon okay time for some things I
like and then some things I hate mildew
the Federalist paper so things I like
over the weekend HBO is recommending I
have Amazon Prime and I subscribe to HBO
so one of HBO's documentaries is is this
fascinating documentary called going
clear now it started off as a book and
the book itself is quite good the
documentary is quite frightening if
you've never followed what the
Scientologists believe or what they do
what the Church of Scientology is this
is a really good introduction and it is
scary it is quite scary it's also scary
insofar as it's not that hard to get
people to believe a lot of kooky crazy
things and I say this is a religious
person who believe some kooky crazy
things right I mean the fact is that it
is not that hard to find to get people
to believe stuff that is damaging to
themselves and this is true whether you
are secular or whether you're religious
because Scientology is not really
particularly religious right the draw to
Scientology the original draw
Scientology is psychological right it's
we are going to better you we're gonna
make you stronger we're gonna make you a
better version of you it's only when you
reach the upper levels of Scientology
they start giving you all the weird
stuff about Xenu and thetans and all
that kind of stuff
but it just shows how people who are who
are looking for answers can be gold into
a lot of crazy stuff here's a little bit
of the preview for going clear
Scientology and the prison of belief
someone had told me there's this cult
and they didn't make anything possible
in your life I was deeply convinced that
we were going to save the world
it was transcendent experience you feel
you for everything you do for endless
trillions of years depends what you
doing with it in Scientology they sell
it all in the beginning of something
quite logical you take on a matrix of
thought that is not your own so strong
it's okay the the documentary is really
good it does it does investigate John
Travolta's relationship with Scientology
and Tom Cruise's relationship with
Scientology it is super creepy
check it out going clear okay time for a
thing that I hate to actually have a
couple of things that I hate today the
first thing that I hate there is this
tweet that had at last count it was
deleted but it had almost two million
views I believe on this on this little
video and it is a person who is berating
a small Jewish child I mean this kid can
hold this kid maybe for I mean this kid
looks at the age of my daughter maybe
and this is a pathetic kid from probably
Crown Heights New York I'm walking
around wearing a yarmulke and what some
of the more Hasidic members of the
community do is because they believe
that you're supposed to let your
sidewalks grow the kid has really long
side locks and the kids hair is cut
really really short so here is the is so
here is this video that it was being
mocked right the kid was being mocked as
a small child a mocked for his parents
religion here is here's this kid who
who's getting mocked it then again this
thing had like two million views on
Twitter and everybody laughing at the
kid and these stupid people who would do
this to the kid if the guys standing
there mocking the kid he's not mocking
the parent she's mocking the kid here's
what it sounded like he's just gonna
keep looking at I'll be crying if I look
like that to brought us would they be
doing it yeah I ain't gonna hold you but
I'll be saying that's like bro
you probably had the full washing set
you should be fired probably then could
you don't bro is your life okay that
that guy is just it's an awful person
but if you looked at the Twitter
comments it was all anti-semitic crap
about how dare they they you know these
terrible terrible parents I promise you
that these kids parents this kid's
parents right here they're better
parents than the guy who's talking the
guy who's talking that guy had crappy
parents you know how I know connect has
a piece of human debris okay and it
what's amazing is it
of course there been a couple of
beatings of a Hasidic guys in New York
in the last few weeks like anti-semitic
beatings Hasidic guys in New York in the
last couple of weeks it's been largely
unremarked upon by national media
because only certain only certain
beatings get actually covered by the
national media if there's an
Islamophobic beating for example and
Islamophobic attack well-deserved media
coverage if there's an anti-semitic
attack only if it's Trump supporter if
it's an alright guy for example then it
gets media but if it's if it's a black
guy attacking a Hasidic kid in New York
which is what that sounds like then and
if you look at the comments and the
person who tweeted it out the person who
tweeted out black then then it's totally
fine right no comment at all this is
pure anti-semitism the idea that
anti-semitism only exists on the
alt-right is idiotic it is not true it
is false it's if you look at the polls
anti-semitism inside the black community
is much higher than anti-semitism in the
white community which is a real problem
it's something that needs to be dealt
with internally in the black community
but it's it's it's it's really really
gross you know the media won't cover any
of this stuff because you're not allowed
to say that that the intersectional
coalition actually has fault lines that
black people that the the polls show
that the black community has more of an
anti-semitism problem than the white
community because obviously blacks are
supposed to be allied with Jews and all
of them are supposed to be allied
against the white power structure but
that is not the reality the reality is
that there are serious fault lines
between a lot of these communities and
those need to be rectified in all
directions
okay other things that I hate so Alyssa
Milano decided to show up to the NRA
event over the weekend and she brought
along her security guard while her
security guard was armed and the NRA
member pointed out that Alyssa Milano
was walking around with an armed
security guard and she got really
uptight
[Applause]
[Music]
elissa you're a hypocrite but you are
you have armed security here armed
security okay and then she claimed that
you know the security was armed which is
highly unlikely okay as somebody who
travels in security I know in my
security is armed I know what my
security is not armed by the way this is
a public forum so moving this guy off of
the sidewalk as long as he's not
disturbing anyone is not actually a
thing but it just goes to show you the
hypocrisy the left when it comes to gun
control it only extends so far as there
are security guards okay now time for a
federalist paper every week we do a
federalist paper here on the bench
shapiro show we are all the way up to
federalist number 27 Alexander Hamilton
wrote this one and it is all about the
fears that the federal government would
use the military to execute its laws now
this Federalist paper is kind of weird
because it actually has some holes in it
Hamilton argues that the people are not
gonna have to worry about the federal
government cracking down using federal
troops because they're only going to
rebel people are only gonna rebel if the
government sucks he says quote I believe
it may be laid down as a general rule
that the American people's confidence in
and obedience to a government will
commonly be proportion to the goodness
or badness of its administration so
therefore if they administer well you're
not gonna have to worry about the
military that's not really a very good
argument right that's that's an argument
like well I'm worried that the police
are gonna come into my community and
harm me and the answer is well if you
obey the laws then the police won't come
and harm you well what if the laws were
the question what if they what if the
extent of the of the laguardia is the
question itself okay then Hamilton
continues he says I will in this place
hazard an observation which will not be
less just because to some it may appear
new which is that the more the
operations of the National Authority are
intermingled in the ordinary exercise of
government the more of the citizens are
accustomed to meet with it the common
occurrences of their political life the
more it is familiarized to their sight
into their feelings but further it
enters into those objects which touch
the most sensible chords and put the
motion put in motion the most active
springs of the human
the greater will be the probability that
it will conciliate the respect and
attachment of the community in other
words the more regular intercourse you
have with the federal government the
more you are going to be likely to obey
its commands but at the same time this
should be a case for the federal
government doing less right because that
is true the more you deal the federal
government the more you become dependent
on the federal government what Hamilton
is using as a as a an argument in favor
of a military stand a standing military
at the national level should actually be
used as an argument in favor of less
federal intervention because the fact is
the more the government is interacting
with you on a daily basis the more
you're going to accept them interacting
with you on a daily basis which they
should not be in the first place I think
this argue actually cuts in the opposite
direction of how Hamilton wants it to
cut okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with all the latest as always i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018